el expresidente Alejandro Toledo reveló
a la fiscalía que el ex mandatario Pedro
Pablo kuczynski cuando fue ministro de
economía durante su gobierno llevó a
Marcelo odebrecky Jorge barata
principales directivos de la
constructora brasileña odebrecht al
palacio de gobierno a un saludo
protocolar medios locales detallan que
en su confesión Toledo le detalló al
fiscal José Domingo Pérez la labor de
kuczynski en su gobierno donde ocupó los
cargos de ministro de economía y Primer
Ministro además de haber impulsado y
firmado el decreto del organismo Estatal
proinversión con la información brindada
por Toledo la fiscalía ha establecido
presuntos manejos que kuczynski habría
ejercido desde su cargo de ministro de
economía por eso el Ministerio Público
acusa Pedro Pablo kuczynski de
supuestamente integrar una red criminal
que habría recibido más de 12 millones
de dólares de odebrecht y otras
compañías mediante asesorías encubiertas
por los proyectos Olmos irsa y rutas de
Lima kuchinski ha negado en todo momento
haber trabaja pero si ha admitido que
sus empresas de las que señaló haber
estado separado habrían ejecutado
consultorías los abogados de Pedro Pablo
kuczynski tratan de liberarlo de los 35
años de cárcel que la fiscalía ha
solicitado contra el expresidente